i'm glad to show you tower
for the platform start page firstly we
need to go
to data integration and manifold
and modern
zone
when we choose the manifold utilities
section
now we
on the page
where we can process our datasets with
one of manifold learning approaches
which we talked about earlier
such as either map l e
spectral
umap
diffusion maps and other
here we can select the
type of data set it can be object
features table
or distance matrix for graph
which will be
used as precomputed graph for
manifold method
let's get
object features table
for mice expression dataset
and upload it to the platform
if you already know about
classes of our objects we can upload
table with this information too
or if you don't know about it we can
skip this step
ok we are ready to choose
the
approach
manifold learning
let's start
try
umap
approach
and this page shows us a small
description
of
method and it parameters
advanced users
can change
all of these parameters
each parameters
has each parameter has description
which we get
by hovering the mouse our eye icon near
parent
newbies in manifold learning can be
can save
default parameters and move to the next
step we press save button
now i am filling the name of our
pipeline
for example
test
the map
nice
and
okay
now our simple pipeline is ready to
start
and let's run
we need to wait for a little time for
the pipeline to finish
while data processing we can look at
input data format
in this
data set
each row is expression values of
70 proteins
the classes
of
each object
written in the following format
column with
objects id
and classes
let's return to our pipeline
when pipeline
will be finished
the
email
will be sent
on
my
email
okay ready
let's click download output files and
we can choose
a png picture of our data manifold
embedding visualization
or you can
choose with txt
file with the points coordinates
let's check a visualization
great your map approach works
we can see dividing of samples into two
clusters
control samples and threesome samples
okay
it is all